it's pretty bad and I don't see anybody
blocking I think we're just uh I'm just
trying to block but it's not work
you spammer this [ __ ] on oh oh my god oh
my god and well Wow who's ambience [ __ ]
crying oh hey hey hey I didn't know you
were you into like you I'm sorry
Oh three times they called out yeah I
just thought you're a say my name cuz
you like it oh my god wait so what are
you guys are you ninjas or Eve I Kings
are some I'm a Viking
yeah and crazy night I don't know what
banana is I'm also first plugging oh my
god I push the [ __ ] office in our
time yeah there's banana banana you
haven't talked at all I know
alright the match started in my heart
rate went up like a hundred percent free
huh
[ __ ] oh my god oh is this tuning off
who's who always hearing it just finally
saw a Spartan yeah only one oh wow FK
hey Duncan whoever that is who's your
guy think coursing y'all get out here
whoa you throw your shield mister their
shield
oh my oh my god
I think render is going to be there oh
my god I please help my oh hey you want
me a mercy Julia I got two yes please oh
okay you're welcome you're welcome
good lord heal oh look at this guy
it's like whew go back to nervous tell
anybody
doctor I need everyone to death with a
[ __ ] bat whoa hey all right I swear
to god the shield does not a damn thing
oh [ __ ] me Jesus oh I didn't mean oh my
god this is so exciting
whoa there's a cluster [ __ ] come on and
walk into this who's over here at the
edge I see mark over here I'd like two
people water just killed you tell your
buddies
oh we sorry mark sorry you can I be I
blame the game it's the game I'm not bad
you killed her two ninjas in a row oh I
get it
I've been losing stamina I can't block
when I have no stamp oh that guy your
daughter with your back oh God
hush oh but you'll be just like you
I'm scared a dog to the most oh my god
yeah she's just destroying everyone
she's got a [ __ ] bat it's in its
unstopping just oh I could never beat
zippers huh why me what what what's that
what's that huh yeah who I thought
that's not here tonight hours a night
[ __ ] up beer Viking Oh God oh [ __ ]
oh gotta go come here come on I got a
spear you're right oh I you can't come
here from Herod I just ah whoa what's up
spear hey my dick no isn't it ha I'm out
of here
screw you guys how about my [ __ ] no are
you using booty like that to could play
that game night good I throw my lessons
Rick I'm uh I'm over here at the end
oh [ __ ] wait shh agreed oh yeah of
people hey come here come here I wanna
punch you my brain does not function
Rollo's
input oh [ __ ] up somebody's fellow i/o I
did was like five people in the code
over here
yeah oh no no how about god oh my god
got a block [ __ ] mark help me get see me
duh where is it Highness I don't know
who QB is just wrecked us or no banana
rectus what Lana good God Oh did some I
killed a lot of people I feel no remorse
oh my god I got that Noah stars [ __ ]
balls
there we go
oh and wait maybe some more bird
I threw my spirit to his jaw Oh bat on
the ice
oh my god I swear Dodgers and a crying
help me
kills into sorry oh he was killing you
I'm sorry how much time is left out can
we don't easily oh that's a lot of
people gonna split so I'm not sure yeah
yeah yes yes okay yeah oh oh [ __ ]
Dodger again yeah don't call me doctor
you gotta go crazy at the end oh [ __ ] oh
no swing
oh come on I won that battle Oh God I
can't get a kill to save my life I know
I sort of made sure I started doing
really badly and oh right
ow oh geez I switch everybody it was
that it was that [ __ ] Club that was
unbelievable unbelievable
where's the leaderboard no honey better
than that mark you [ __ ] wrecked what
are you talking about or you're saying
you were doing crap yeah I mean I'm just
normally the best I don't know I don't
have a joke for that